previously on raft more can you play
back before ya lead rappin for my rap
pro rap expert anybody have any opinions
on where to put this sale before we just
go for it I don't know anything about
this mark you're a sail placement really
did oh I can move it my chairs would
have been not so good oh my god that's a
bad place for a sail isn't it I've
discovered a flaw in your plan yes sir
we are fully extended with nets nice
foliage look at all this loot world
we're sailing into for that weird thanks
man
I was not Bob I was not complimenting
him thanks man you're you are welcome
but he is not thanks man
make sure you're staying hydrated on you
it's I might not have refilled it did I
reflect really oh no it's fine it's fine
seagulls here tonight
yeah when do you sleep you a-holes so
other than clothes all right sorry we're
back corner our ship so big we can't
even get to it our huge ship is so you
we need to build it like a second floor
we need to stop going like out and more
up okay you do that
oh yeah it's in the Builder it should be
like if you have the Builder thing you
can build it Wade you're our resident
builder you know I'll get to Wade the
Builder yeah yeah I guess there's
nothing else we really need right now
other than it was just me we gotta get
clay that's just it if we don't get clay
we're doomed
Bob good catch
the music what if what cues the music
why is it so random it's very loud when
it comes in yeah not that I don't like
it but I just like a purpose behind it
what streamer I'm a streamer
oh I'm drowning mark what are you doing
no I mean drowning by drowning I mean
I'm dying of thirst oh my goodness
there's no water
it's cranking that's my bit for me eat
some watermelon eat some watermelon
watermelon yeah three delicious
watermelon please one for me please just
just one tasty water not wood and this
is what I have to show for it so
apparently second floors are expensive
it's like I'm playing Animal Crossing a
good one
thanks man what a relatable reference I
made a streamer so we know which way the
wind is blowing so we got that or if I
turn this the way the wind is blowing it
that'll blow us oh yeah
what an [ __ ] what an [ __ ] where
have there been no islands where's my
pillars yeah are we not supposed to
borrow should we be finding islands I
feel like we're not finding Islands wait
what's the islands really maybe we were
supposed to spend more time there
something I don't know probably probably
should have figure out how many of the
bricks we needed before we got the thing
it doesn't make sense weird it's all a
big lie I agree with you that's scary
and we agree well don't disagree with me
I'm making myself a big planter and
we're gonna have more Malone's I'm
actually out of Malone seeds but we have
eleven taters actually I have more now I
want to grow potatoes let's see what
happens no get out of here you [ __ ] you
really don't want to fall in when the
shark is literally waiting to catch you
no food and water I should probably take
a moment no we got plenty don't you
don't you let yourself go hungry in this
universe
we're cata we're gonna how did we make a
raised foundation I don't know isn't the
way the Builder why are you doing
weights job okay
I mean I just wanted to know what it was
like why you trying to steal wasting
Island dead ahead we're headed right for
it yes nice nice nice nice
okay we're Spears murder shark it's
taken quite a bit of damage since the
last time and then hopefully wait Bob
what a miss I was gonna get it patience
patience was going to get me there Oh
miss your inclination was to yell at me
wait what didn't what an assumption Wow
and what an assumption Oh like that way
to assume boom get your Spears at the
ready we got a shark the murder the [ __ ]
out us anchor away do we want a Wang
into the island or now that's fine well
perfect opportunity to kill Oh attack
for sure for real shark attack yeah I
agree
comeback kid [ __ ] I'm back ye [ __ ]
where'd you ask ye [ __ ] it's coming for
me oh it hurts I didn't get a hit yeah I
see him smiling over there miss me
oh you're going nuts cuz you weren't
going for me I see me dum-dum oh you
missed me by like a mile weren't even
close
oh so are we in combat mode are we
trying to get distracted
yes I can't get a good I got one hit
there we go come here [ __ ] tell alright
alright alright I need some oxygen come
on
Oh got another hit kukuku I think that's
clay right below the ship oh you got me
once stand / brick got one B oh my god
alright we might as well get more than
12 just because it's gonna be Oh Frick I
need to take a breather Oh God
pain tag me in tag me in Fran hey got
him whoa alright that means I'm less I'm
going for it I'm going for I see there's
stone I think this is clay oh this is
copper copper you know what coppers for
yeah this is clay I got clay well I mean
I'm assuming you smelt it well yeah I
just dealt it or
yeah this is why I'm such a successful
streamer because of this company here I
got two bolts out of a chest that was
underwater whoa wait you you did put one
of the bolts into the research thing
because we need that for like a lot of
recipes guys we're gonna be so wealthy
with potatoes oh hell yeah
potato harvests for two more potatoes
it's infinite potatoes it's infinite
potato family well yeah you got it wait
I have a shark head in my inventory is
that for something you did
where's I killed one yeah we still need
the metal ingot we have to research the
metal ingot to get the grille I see yeah
so we're snow we're almost there were
almost there how much how much clay you
got I don't have any right now cuz I
came up with the bolts he was being lazy
I fished up the area around the raft so
there might not be much over there I'm
just gathering anything that's down here
I'm getting scrapping I'm getting
subnautica vibes around the edges here
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm way out at sea I'm like
shark bait right we fished up stuff to
the shark bait I don't have any uncooked
halibut right now or whatever it's all
cooked
you fool you were cooking up a storm and
you didn't even think about the future I
didn't even think about the future
you're right you're absolutely right
right now I've got eight clay and twelve
sand here's that and that you won't play
oh you want me to make it yes that's
fine all right what brings the research
to hinge oK we've got five we need one
more - we need two more clay okay I
research the hinge as well so we can now
do the hinge we can learn a whole bunch
of recipes which I support all these
just go ahead and learn they're free
Oh big storage oh yeah large crippled
what better look better ax hell yeah
that's good research boys now we'll know
clock things ooh metal fishing rod we
need bolts for all these though okay so
we still need the furnace we need one
more brick we need two more clay we got
to go down and get more clay I am almost
dying of thirst
empty water bottle whoa sweep or net
what the hell is sweep net damn son
where'd you find catching bugs it's what
the hell flippers Oh should I brave the
depths and holy dad oh nice
should I brave the depths and find these
last two clay I think I should yeah
unless you guys got shark bait I don't
have a fishing rod anymore so no more
shark bait okay you guys want to help me
kill it
yeah give me one second we're learning
more [ __ ] here I'm here prim all right
sounds good a jar for a beehive she says
there's so many things here I've never
messed with before yeah alright did you
go in Bob oh we didn't even loot the
island there's like watermelons and [ __ ]
on the island we don't even get well
yeah oh I could stab [ __ ] did you find
the shark man sure did sure did sure did
I'm fighting them i helpless I'm in the
shadow baby yep come on get up by the
boat yeah Clips thin through things too
easy yeah he's like right under us now
oh yeah if you get on the shallows you
can move away over the the shallow Sand
Ridge here you might be able to dodge
them got him could get hit who's there
coming that I don't even see him yeah
you you me Rick I'm okay I might need to
take a break here let me take some it's
I'm good he'll I'm gonna third something
to go up yeah it's okay
I can take a mono e mono
where are you from hell's heart I stab
at me where's ego is it gone or
something no farm if it's gone I scared
it away he's eating the boat oh that's
why you went away I managed to get one
clay uh it's also really hard to [ __ ]
see at night in this game it's okay I'm
sorry
good night with your night where's he
where's Oh
that's so scary come here you ahh oh my
spear broke do you want my spear come at
me [ __ ] it's getting confused Astoria
it must be woozy from blood loss
dick beat in almost it's gotta be he's
got to be low well I see him I love your
battle cry come on so close you gotta be
GOG come on just die I really am trying
to kill this thing you really got the
blood in your eyes one more all I need
is one more clay it's dead good murder
team fam excellent leader we got food
come out our buttholes boys everything's
good
clay baby how do you get vine goo I
don't know we have some how much you
need for well not really I don't need it
it's think we have one I think it comes
from seaweed maybe hmm these potatoes
grow like like potatoes tell you what I
don't know how fast potatoes grow they
grow incredibly fast according to this
video game I won't use this yet wait
till we get the big grill but once we
have a big grill Merry Christmas
Tamara Berg well I can't pick that up
what is that it's a better fishing round
oh cool fancy fish Pole yeah well yeah
we have lots of stuff for the big grill
so all we need to do is get that I think
we might need to get out of here because
we are not getting wood and we're like
tapped out of planks I have we're out of
wood we need wood boys yeah I think our
skills lost its art do I think it's
about it I'm putting I'm putting our
mascots upstairs don't worry okay that's
nice
with a happy kitty cat I am I could use
me pretty kitty lost your marbles why
don't you just calm the hell down judge
emic Jason hi my name is now Jason that
is my brother I need a drink I will be
back to make sure I don't die like oh I
thought you meant in the game I was like
I
you just get it from the thing mark what
are you doing I think we gotta go yeah
that should be fine I think he said we
got enough play and hopefully be enough
I think so I'm thank you for distracting
the shark I mark did you say we're good
on clay how are we good to get out of
here yeah we are good because as soon as
this last brick dries I'm gonna make
this furnace then we're gonna be
smelting up a storm I think it's time to
go my dudes here we go cat damn it get
out of here you scarecrow [ __ ]
well the scarecrows not the [ __ ] I just
have the the sail pointed directly in
the where it says the wind is blowing so
we're happy where we're gonna go oh this
is a brick just dried mark all right
here we go smelter it is baby where do
we want and point me at it I'll plop her
down I would like the spot I'm standing
in for more planters so I guess I'm
maybe a second floor wait I can do
second-story planters do you want to do
smelting on the main floor I can move my
stupid I'm like you could have but you
could have the whole upstairs to
yourself I'm trapped here with Wade
unfortunately it would be the I'm
actually I'm gonna move all my stuff
upstairs I think that's the new plan all
right fair enough smelter right there
for now we can always move it upstairs
till we get a [ __ ] ton more wood
yeah no the upstairs is like fine for me
to just use as it is right now and you
can you don't have to expand it we could
maybe put another water purifier down
here do we have the mats for that yeah
well we can make a better water purifier
seeing a bigger one we just need to
start making glass which I assume is
doing something with sand
can we smelt sand yeah I wouldn't do
them yeah I don't see why not that is
how you make glass so let's be my
assumption there who knows we might
a scientific deduction brainerd calm
calm down buggin nerd calm down he's
nerdy calm down everybody
he's nerd I'm dying Fuu did you get made
you so grumpy mr. grumpy McBride and
thirsty mister maliciously judgey pants
say such a thing about someone else I'm
dying of hunger
oh please chef Bob I'm sorry I insulted
thee might I have a potate take that my
dude oh thank you three most gracious
Lord I was gonna go in the net whatever
I we got a metal ingot do we need to
research this metal ingot I think yes
yeah yeah do it yeah oh wow
Oh metal arrow metal spear baby whoa I
don't even want what this is shear
advanced grill baby oh we have so much
stuff this oh this is beautiful cooking
pot Bob you love me don't you
yes you want to hinge thing I wanted net
launcher oh my god bull oh my god and
anchor dude you love me you know me
you'll love to know me okay come come
you love that you know me calm down hey
there might be a shark attack or
something happening well we're never
mind he's just chillin get out of here
you Seagal bad we are missing a spot I
think we might have been attacked hmm
all right I'll get on it just a second
no no I got it mr. bilder s'en not all
of us cannot build just go around yeah
well
maybe you should maybe that's a good
marker I guess maybe if you did way by
the boat might be lighter and our food
supply would be less strained I guess
that's all I can't argue your cold hard
fact yeah well you know you gotta be
cold nard to succeed in life sometimes
I'd be cold and you gotta be awful you
gotta be hard I don't know what's going
on with Wade he's he's going through
some stuff I'm just gonna leave him be
I'm really trying to boom our potato
economy here friends if we get any scrap
I would like to make another planter
just Hawking that out there I'm hookin
it out there it's just putting out there
no I'm gonna knock your way Bob I have a
gift for you a gift for you for you I'm
gonna put it on the ground I will let
you determine where said gift goes oh my
god a large crop this man this man's
here that's what I do ba this is my
man's right here's that honking thing
hole is it honking is it honking is it
home where do I even where do I even
want to put it right here we're about to
miss up boo I bet my look at this big
old honker I bet it's green oh oh we can
put a tree in that that's what that is
Oh do we have any tree yeah we do we do
we have coconuts don't we yeah coconut
second from the right inventory do you
want palm seeds more than coconuts lots
of palm seeds giving you the coconuts no
no coconut our coconut tree is palm
seeds are palm trees well no wait I
don't know try to put a coconut in I bet
it that's what it is all right well I
planted one we'll see what we gave you
know you love me advanced purifier baby
what do I need for fancy-ass purifier
for glass I have everything I need
except for for glass okay how long has
poor glass gonna take try like it
probably 15 minutes I'm just gonna make
myself a regular purifier for my farming
purposes to anyone no no it's just
planks palm in plastic so it's not
anything super valuable honestly I
I wonder why we don't have multiple
water purifiers yeah well that's what
I've been saying and then someone was
like no we'll just good another one and
I was like okay but then we didn't get
another one that doesn't sound like what
I would say so I think whoever said that
is just out of their gourd out of their
gourd that's what I was gonna say out of
their gourd
yeah we're simpatico same things
thoughts scary sometimes am I crazy is
there land to the do lefty
I believe you can Island on the right -
there's two islands what which one do we
go to it looks like the one to the right
is bigger do we want the bigger island
sure all right all right I'm also rowing
towards it cuz I'm just a team player
man this paddle sucks breaks into shadow
seagull he's just chomping away at the
stupid decoy like an idiot feel like an
idiot yeah it is that is a handy
technique of just being able to build
the thing you need right in them and the
other one that's right isn't that nice
that's a nice I wish that inventories
would do that for like many many a year
and this is one of the fear that I've
ever seen that does that very handy very
good scrap metal before no we're sort of
boned on scraps oh we don't have a
anchor oh that's okay I'll just point it
towards the island it should be fine
yeah it's not working how do we make an
anchor I got an answer I got I can make
one oh wait this asian Arianne ker nope
I got friends it's done nice work done
we've been anchored nice bro nice thank
you
getting it [ __ ] yep God still problem
where is he holy [ __ ] scary
he wanted your bones he really did maybe
he's angry because we keep killing his
family probably but like eventually
they're gonna run out a family alright
yeah the can't breathe that fast are on
the endangered species list a brutally a
parental well sick
thanks it was brutal man thank you two
thing gnarly
ooh there's a crate up here is he dead
there was the signal PC these are here
there were bolts in the crate good
that's free ingots yeah free ingots you
say yeah sweet bolts for long stuff like
I don't know every time Bob needs a new
fishing pole once we get the big grill
you need a bolt for that so I mean
that'll be good for nothing else keeping
food I'll Bowl you say hey Bob gonna
light a present for him yeah I dropped
it there for you Oh my very own storage
I'll be like about I'll be like it oh so
much this will be the food storage yeah
my people
all right sharks still coming no nope
all right friends food storage is
officially upstairs like a restaurant
right yeah Oh get some my dudes how's
the storage looking oh it's big storage
yeah Bob that's something special that's
really nice ah that's a new glass let me
put another in there we've got two of
four needed for the purifier which we're
gonna put upstairs for a Bob I'm gonna
have another gift worm no dude I got my
own little purifier it's run by the Sun
we gotta get it up there culturing the
[ __ ] out of this - wait I'm not gonna
give it away
well you can give it to yourself I don't
want it I don't deserve it I've been a
bad boy I agree
is the shark dead alive what's the
status of the shark alive oh I think
he's still alive oh that's a problem are
you just like wandering around yeah well
I'm kind of like crazy a hole yeah you
know crazy a holes
all right sharks coming at me right now
boys good keep it over there and not
towards me come Sarki [ __ ] yeah you
keep him busy you keep busy I'm on the
way I'm gonna help you
he did what he's in he went under ground
oh my he's quick here really quick
whew are you cuz he went through the
island dude I'm on the other side of the
cliff cuz I was hoping you went straight
through for you yes he did yes he did
the Scarecrow boom oh no not the net did
it get the net saved it oh you're a hero
wait you really did it
wait you're a hero oh my god this it's
so deep it's so deep okay guy is still
alive oh god it's over here come here
you come on try me try me try me
oh really wants you do we have any nails
anywhere
I got nails nails nails nails look for
you bombing off two three but one nail
there you go thank you
you got it anything for you how do you
get a seaweed up do you need an axe I
just grabbed it there's just like a
great you're right you're right you're
right there isn't okay Wow Bob so smart
wheeze I know so many things guys how
about we go to the other Island any
objections to that this one yeah I don't
find any more clay well we need all the
scrap metal you got all the scrap metal
because that's like the thing we were
lowest on uh scrap metal I mean yeah
we're totally boned on scrap metal at
the moment hey Bob can you chuck me that
other piece of glass I have two pieces
of glass hi-yah good thing glass isn't
breakable you know because it is oh we
have no wood it's funny because I have
wood what you need I need eight pieces
for this purifier there's nine pieces
right there my do
we share because we care hey uh Bob here
I'll let you decide where this goes Oh
do you want to take the other one
downstairs
since I already got one or do I get all
the purifiers you know all the beer
revoir you're gonna need a lot of them
Hey
do Oh what the f what do I do with that
I think you fill it with liquid let me
let me see what's going on here
how do I right now I'm not complaining
but you couldn't get water from up here
mark because you have the longest arms
in the history of arms oh wow oh wow
you can't oh you know this thing oh my
god this is gonna be like a basin of
fresh water it's topped off all right oh
I spotted you from a mile away
irony's it's dead I did this I did this
this is excellent
guys we get so much water from this
frickin thing holy geez yeah if you get
I um if we get the bottle it can hold
like three drinks worth but we need the
vine goo which means we need to get the
seaweed
I believe well yeah you've got two
seaweed in the smelter and it turns into
goo I'm just gonna see how long it takes
have you tapped this island out no I'm
on the opposite side I'm still finding a
lot of metal I don't know if any more
clams no grabbing the clams to ruin the
clams grab these clams hey what's that
what is that grab my clams dude new
purifier is the Jimmy jams I tell you
what is it it is sounds pretty sweet bro
goddamn dimmadome up in here clams are
balls thanks Chet
all right cool neck better good you know
clams are balls man clams are balls bro
dude your clams are boobs
Bob might die spare some food come to
the restaurant sir put some shirts in
there for you bro
thank you yeah I need like a bunch more
planters but otherwise we're rocking and
rolling what do you need to make
planters
I need more scrap metal that's the thing
I need for planters wait here just take
my scrap metal here Oh
drop me daddy huh oh my god you had 8
scrap yeah of course 6 6 scrap I mean
dude I'm always sitting on the scrap
shall we anchors up we can go let's just
get out of here I will continue growing
things like the absolute boss that I am
oh sorry there's pointed in the wrong
direction there we go
are you driving us into the it's all
hard to say quantifiably yeah I don't
think what I felt in the short back
right as I fell in all right we really
need that big grill I have so much shark
meat and [ __ ] to [ __ ] and what do you
need for it big grill is planks metal
ingot to two ropes and six nails and I
have the planks and half the nails
already so you see two metal nails
daughter to love me bro
this is this us to me do - we do - we do
- wait yeah all you all you are about to
love me you're about to love me you will
love me you will oh my god love me I all
I need is two ropes and we have palm
fronds somewhere you will be loving me
oh my god are you guys some unbelievably
delicious foods yes I'm about to
absolutely chef you out of your mind
hole and chef my Hall I can cook three
big hunks as meat at the time at the
same time oh my god how is your mind
hole feeling how are you
how are you even living right now I
think I've died dude we're on a whole
other level this is awesome guys this is
nice
teamwork really does make the dream work
it's like they've said so many times
before like the Dave Matthews Band has
said like the Dave Matthews Band has
said you know yeah yeah yeah because
it's a bad singer that's right
that's right Dave Matthews Band fans we
have so much plastic right now do we
need to expand anywhere on the main
floor I don't think so
we're doing pretty good my food Empire
is just utterly beyond compare right now
no one would have thought you would have
been top-tier world top ten food Empire
of raft ST Ren a raft gameplay happening
right now live on stream yeah we have
any more planks I'm plumb out of flanks
my dude so you're getting on it at the
moment there's planks I got the blanks I
need your sweet little scrote about
how's that super purifier doing up there
dude it is an absolute dream of mine
even come to fruition lo this [ __ ] it's
just fully spammable 24/7
dude this is spanked out of my mouth out
of its mind juice and beyond belief and
what's amazing is you can just fill it
as you clogged it you don't need to
compromise
look how honkin this one salmon is I'm
grilling up a salmon and it takes the
whole [ __ ] thing holding how do you
like my salmon whoa you're holding it
like a bazooka well here look this is
the shark steaks these are cooked eggs
oh my god it's like a third of your
hunger barred one chomp you got one of
those for
get yourself get yourself something get
yourself guys the restaurant just got
upgraded my dude was amazing your
restaurant is best restaurant top - your
restaurant
the unfortunate thing about the purifier
being up here is refilling it's gonna be
you can get water from the top you have
arms like a god
yeah all you must do is out stretch them
my mind is what did you blow your mind
to her I blew too hard
like you said oh my god you get an
entire cooked salmon when you got cooked
salmon funny about this weight you can
do got the shoe oh you caught that I
caught that on my fishing my fishing
next bill is only here you can plant
something in the shoe oh you can use the
shoe as a planter good I'm on the water
the shoe plan adorable [ __ ] I've ever
heard of alright beaten the shoe oh my
god guys we are utterly wealthy with
potatoes I cannot overstate this to you
I mean you could try we have so many
potatoes that we could literally build a
bridge from here to the moon out of
potatoes and we would still have several
potatoes damn that's a lot of potato
right
oh the scrap hook is way better oh yeah
oh this thing lightning speed what it's
what it's what it's time to be alive
dude who needs a land I don't even know
what I love raft and I am here for raft
ice and raft so hard dude
iced and raft so hard come on daddy
needs a new pair of slippers baby yeah
oh we're being a nah oh no did he get
the net
well you you're big boy you can make
more nets problems yeah I mean morning
itch that's it that's the spirit
hey you friends got any planks yes in
this leftmost one I'm putting planks
small oh yeah just the basic basic stuff
I'm gonna keep in that one oh you got
whole stacks of things just stacks on
stacks big stacks on racks on stacks on
stacks have you seen the pile q and a
good break for my routine style crank
out of Shawshank or a Green Mile right
mmm yep oh my god guys one cooked salmon
basically D hungers you oh my god this
is the most satisfied I've been in a
long time very nice
also this water purifier is [ __ ] Dole
and your booze done - mark mark was
making this bread sea water night drinks
like I do I've really doing it ruins it
cuz I just drank some of the fresh water
has nothing fine I have nothing to call
my own I guys look at me and tell me if
I'm okay by the way I thought we were
going towards another Island but
apparently there's no other islands this
is it seems like it's ready it's pretty
big and honkin if you know what I mean I
expected people like coconuts dangling
they don't see but ya think so ready
alright well here we go let's do it you
got to chop it I think so
oh my god from it yeah yeah just
replaying it all again water that bad
boy I'll drink the water in front of the
tree just to make it feel bad about
itself Wow that's Rebecca that's the
most savage [ __ ] I've ever done to a
tree I walked up to him with a delicious
cup of water it was all mmm god that's
good
some people treat some people treat
haters wait do we have a clam
Leah claims them over the check yeah
where's clam can you claim I'm about to
solve our troubles seagull nest where do
you want it it needs to be far away from
people cuz it people scared because we
don't want to scare it away when it's on
the nest yeah no I used this whole top
area can you put it on one of the
counters down there where yeah done it's
done baby immediately like ha ha that's
for me yeah 2 seconds later
[Music]